well in my my youngest side and she's 22
when she thought she saw very very early
cut she is not a real fan of you know
she doesn't a j't 8 for me to take her
to the Broadway or to the musical as
much but and she's sort of a serious
girl and she's set forward and she
watched the whole thing she didn't laugh
a lot even at the funny parts and so I
was afraid at the end I didn't know what
her reaction was because she's sort of
unreadable and she turned to me at the
end and she said I love every single
thing about this movie and I said Wow
and I I said what was it that really
interested you she said there's a scene
in the second half after everybody gets
their wish when the world changes and
Cataclysm happens and she was a fifth
grader when we lived in New York when
9/11 happened and it was her second day
in a new school and her bus stopped at
the World Trade Center at 8:15 in the
morning and then continued on under the
tunnel to Brooklyn and so she lived
through that time and she was a kid and
she said the floating debris that little
those little pieces of paper in the air
after the forest comes down she said
that reminded me of that day and and so
it made me think yes bad things happen
in the world and children are aware of
them and this is a way how it resolves
at the end is an interesting
prescription for
hope that's that's a great story
but too many people the which might be
perceived as the villain in the story
but in reality she sort of has the
clearest vision of anyone in the piece
right can you talk about that well the
witch yeah I guess she sets things in
motion as most conflagrations begin with
in cycles of revenge you know something
was done to her and so she's going to do
it to someone else and and it's in
service of something that she really
wants which is for her daughter to love
her and never leave her and embedded in
that or all sorts of things that parents
understand worried about what's out in
the outside world
you know being hyper protective of kids
and that's all in her motivation to
retain her daughter's love and it's
wrongheaded but sometimes we all are
that's veterans for sure nice is
different than good is it also an
important message in the film can you
talk about how that line sort of informs
the character of the witch
well the witch gets her wish which is
that she comes into her beauty again her
youth and beauty and you know she gets
that wish she has every you know
imaginable surgery and procedure and
injection and whatever it is you know
whatever the modern equivalent of
getting your wish to have your beauty
back and yet what is it
what is it you know it's it does her
daughter doesn't stay with her and love
her because she's beautiful
her daughter loved her when she looked
perfectly horrible but you know it's it
it is there's so many little
negotiations in the summit's wisdom in
every person's story you know what each
one covets and then they get it and then
it isn't quite what they thought and
presents its own set of problems well
some time is very complex like life life
is very complex and and it doesn't this
this musical doesn't talk down to its
audience whether the adults in it or the
children and in Sondheim being it sort
of complicated and knowing that it's
hard enough to convey emotions through
spoken dialogue when you add sometimes
music and lyrics to the process how do
you tackle that does that make it that
much harder no that makes the lyric
married to an incredibly beautiful
melody and full score is something
that's like riding in the best car you
could ever imagine
the ride is smooth and and you can trust
where you're going and for me that that
music it offers so many possibilities of
feeling and musicality and it it holds a
very high bar to get over and you know
everything about it is thrilling I just
never got tired of singing the songs my
family got tired of it tonight at I
still
I love the music and not just my own I
love all the music it's really really
one of them when that little boy jumps
into the tree and says there are diets
in the sky is so much excitement it's
it's just about the discovery of youth
and possibility outside your own little
house and ah I mean there's so much in
this musical it gets stuck in your head
yeah it really does into the woods I
think a lot of people would say is
sometimes most pointy at work and it's
obviously it deals with issues that are
still very relevant today there's always
going to be a giant in the world that we
all sort of have to come together as a
community to fight can you talk about
that elemental when my son was a little
boy I was disturbed because he kept
drawing these monsters you know and he's
a very good artist and we lived in a
beautiful place and I thought why
doesn't he draw the lake and the trees
and the island and he would draw these
things you know that were just and I
think kids get themselves ready for
their fears and to confront them and
they know they know as safe as their
world is there's stuff out there that's
scary
and you gotta get ready for it little
boys you know we're obsessed with
superheroes and and fighting monsters
and and so it's it's in us it's in our
DNA to to have fear and and to get ready
for trouble because troubles coming no
matter what you do
and so these fairy tales kind of were
way of you know feeding the fear in a
way of keeping children safe by making
them fearful and you know don't talk to
strangers and all those things but I
think yeah I think it's it's
understandable absolutely
and sort of long the same line it's you
know with important themes like the
parent-child relationship which is
captured so beautifully and children
will listen can you can you talk about
that and what you hope audiences will
take away when they leave the theater
with them well I'm not sure you take
away something as much as you have
awakened in you stuff you already knew
you know it's so deep the themes of it
are so deep that you'll what happened
when I saw the film was that it sort of
awakens something you already you
already know about relationships and and
the complexity and the forgiveness
necessary in all parts of it it's very
tender compassionate movie in the end
and just again it's that music it's the
music that just
it stays with you
you